- [Instructor] We are
asked to draw the image
of triangle ABC under a dilation
whose center is P and scale factor is 1/4.
So pause this video, and at least think
about how you would do this.
You don't have access
to the tool that I do
where I can move this around.
This is actually from the
Khan Academy exercise.
But at least think about
how you would do this.
Draw the image of triangle A, B, C
under a dilation whose center is P
and scale factor is 1/4.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So one way to think about it is
our center of dilation is P,
and our scale factor is 1/4,
so for each of these points,
however far they were from P before,
they're now going to be 1/4 as far.
And one way to think about it is
is to think about it in each
of the x and the y dimensions.
So for example, point A right over here,
to get from point P to point A,
you have to go one, two,
three, four to the right
and one, two, three, four down.
So 1/4 of that in the
x and the y direction,
instead of going four to
the right and four down,
1/4 of that would be one
to the right and one down
'cause one is 1/4 of four.
So instead of four to the
right, we'd go one to the right,
and instead of four down,
we would go one down.
So this is what point
A would get mapped to,
and now let's think about point B.
In order to go from P to point B,
you have to go in the Y
direction up one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight.
Well, what's 1/4 of eight?
It's two, so now we're gonna go up two,
and to go from P to B,
how much do we have to
go in the x direction?
Well, we have to go to the
left one, two, three, four.
So instead of going four to the left,
we're now going to go 1/4 of that
or just one to the left.
So instead of eight up and four left,
we're now going two up
and one to the left,
1/4 in each direction.
And then last but not
least, to go from P to C,
it looks like we're going
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight to the left,
and one, two, three, four up.
So if we take 1/4 of each of those,
instead of eight to the left,
we're now going to go two to the left.
Instead of four up, we're
now going to go one up.
And we're done.
We have just created the
image of triangle ABC
under a dilation whose
center is P (chuckling)
and scale factor is 1/4.